the 2020 presidential election is set to
be one of the closest and ugliest in
modern American history choice between
slippy Joe and crazy Bernie Donald Trump
determine not to go down as a one-term
president is firing up his base the
Democrats are desperate to pick the
candidate most likely to beat him but
how can they know who that is
Paul after poll shows that the
overriding priority for most Democrats
is beating Donald Trump in the 2020
election with this work against Trump
could this beat Trump with this get
Trump out of the White House even if
that candidate doesn't completely share
their political views Donald Trump is a
stronger candidate than his low approval
rating suggests generally incumbent
presidents who are dealing with very
strong economies are in almost
unbeatable positions for reelection he
filed his re-election campaign paperwork
that Davey got sworn in
no presidents ever done that he's been
running for election from day one
despite three years of political tumult
lack of serious legislative
accomplishments and impeachment trial
Donald Trump looks poised for a roughly
50/50 shot at reelection
we will but those fighting to lead the
Democrats are divided over what to offer
Americans in Trump's place you've got
Joe Biden the former vice president
Bernie Sanders the Democratic Socialist
Elizabeth Warren the wonkish reformer
Pete buta jej the former Mayor Michael
Bloomberg the self-made self-funding
billionaire and Amy Klobuchar the
moderate Midwestern ER
candidates fight it out in a series of
state primaries and caucuses to be the
Democratic victor who could be Donald
Trump's most forceful foe the best place
to start is to look at how Barack Obama
won the presidency in 2008 in 2012
Barack Obama won the presidency by
creating a coalition that had never been
created before we have the most diverse
coalition of Americans Barack Obama
United a diverse range of groups he
brought in young old rich and poor
college-educated whites and did well
enough with white working-class voters
it was part message part motivation part
one you passed the the eight years of
Bush and he balanced somewhat liberal
positions with the pragmatic streak as a
candidate the so-called Obama coalition
has taken on an almost mythical
significance for Democrats Hillary
Clinton tried to replicate it in 2016
and found Hillary Clinton lost support
among african-american voters but they
were more importantly less likely to
turnout than they were in 2012 her
losses among white working-class voters
in the Midwestern states were
particularly harmful the right votes in
the right places are what counts in 2016
Hillary Clinton actually won the popular
vote by almost 3 million but she lost
the election because in America
presidents aren't directly elected by
the people who vote for them voters
actually determine which candidate will
get the support of their state in the
electoral college process
the bigger the state's population the
more votes it has to decide the
presidency in almost every state the
party that wins the state's popular vote
gets all of the state's electoral
college votes Hillary Clinton won huge
margins of voters and large states like
New York and California Clinton won
almost two million more votes than Trump
in New York which translated to her
winning 29 electoral college votes she
lost by slim margins and crucial states
in the Midwest Clinton lost Wisconsin
Michigan and Pennsylvania by nearly 78
thousand votes yet it cost her 46
electoral college votes and the election
the battle in 2020 will be played out in
the same three states in the Midwest
Barack Obama was victorious in all three
states in 2008 and 2012 recreating the
Obama coalition is still the Democrats
best bet to beat Trump
it's a low-risk strategy that has proven
successful in the past
a majority of college-educated whites
are almost guaranteed to vote for
Democrats in 2020 whoever the candidate
is the real challenge is to appeal to
the two groups that cost Clinton the
presidency working-class whites and
african-americans Joe Biden performs
well in primary polling among both
African Americans and among white
working-class voters he is the candidate
that's best placed to resemble the Obama
coalition while Joe Biden has enjoyed
the most support from African Americans
his popularity with this group is
falling
it's questionable whether or not he
could turn out non-white and young
voters who frankly aren't very enthused
by his campaign but have just supported
him as a sort of default Obama asked
option in the primaries Biden is going
to be defending Obama and his ability to
explain that record and defend it and
compare it to Trump's is going to be
what's going to decide the election in a
trump Biden race and I just don't think
Biden is anywhere near as compelling a
communicator as Bob ama was poor kids
are just as bright and just as talyn's
white kids if Joe Biden won't turn out
the youth could a younger candidate
unlock the Obama coalition Pete Budaj
former mayor of a mid-sized city in
Indiana enjoyed an unexpected primary
search it's clear Joe Biden sees puget
debt as a threat
mocking his inexperience in a recent
campaigner Joe Biden helped save the
auto industry which revitalized the
economy of the Midwest compete Budaj
edge revitalized the sidewalks of
downtown South Bend while some cool Pete
Berg edges charisma Obama like
recreating Obama's coalition is likely
to be out of reach for him booter judge
has almost almost zero visible
african-american support anywhere and
Pete food to judge actually performs
worse than Joe Biden with the young his
lack of support with key voters means
Donald Trump would likely beat him in a
general election one moderate believes
there's another way to build a coalition
to beat Donald Trump Minnesota senator
Amy Klobuchar is foregoing Barack
Obama's diverse coalition in favor of a
simpler strategy she's pinning all of
her hopes on winning over the white
working-class voters in the key states
in the Midwest on which the election
hinges she represents a sort of middle
ground middle risk middle reward
strategy for the presidency in which he
simply wins well in the Midwest which is
crucial for the electoral college and
thus wins the presidency Amy Klobuchar
polls closely against Donald
in a theoretical matchup and has a
history of state victories to back up
her campaign she's won in her state of
Minnesota statewide elections for US
Senate by overwhelming margins and she's
won in rural areas she's won suburban
areas and she's won in urban areas
she truly understands the Midwest and so
I think she she would automatically put
Michigan Pennsylvania Wisconsin in play
in a way no other candidate would yet
nationally among Democrats Amy Klobuchar
pulls badly it's very hard to run for
president and not be a national figure
when you start and because of that she
has to had real trouble raising money
and convincing donors and voters and she
has a path to being the nominee
moderates Biden booted edge and
Klobuchar are advocating for small
repairs to improve America rather than
revolution if you are tired of the
extremes in our politics you have a home
with me yet an extreme populist position
is exactly what progressives Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren are banking
on for success they have radical plans
for the government and for a radically
different coalition to get them there
they think that they can juice turnout
among why young disaffected
working-class voters the radicals argue
these disaffected voters have been
neglected by the Democrats for years
they're aiming to win them back with
class struggle and economic populism I
am prepared to stand with the working
class of this country and take on the
greed and corruption of the corporate
elite rather than the racial politics
that Donald Trump has put at the
forefront of his campaigns local
officials order police to release
dangerous criminal aliens to prey upon
the public bernie sanders as strength is
drawn from voters who really want to
blow up the system
the young and the white working-class
are particularly embracing his approach
Sanders is running fully on Medicare for
all fully on green New Deal fully on
raising taxes in big government oh
you're ready for a political revolution
it's a high-risk strategy but could
conceivably work if they can sell their
transformative message this strategy
should not be underestimated
surprisingly around 19 percent of
Republicans have economically
progressive views if Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren
succeed in making politics more about
economics than race some of these voters
might be ripe for the picking by
Democrats yet they're ideologically
extreme positions may energize Donald
Trump's supporters to go out and vote
against them there are some big risks
the political science research tells us
that a moderate candidate tends to do
better in presidential elections and
that's because both they can pull some
swing voters their way and more
importantly they don't inflame the
passions of the other party and get them
to the polls Warren and Sanders are
talking about tens of trillions of
dollars of new spending massive spending
on all kinds of programs you'll see
Trump make Sanders or Warren up here
very extreme in terms of their proposals
I think he's a communist I mean you know
look I think of communism what I think
of Bernie Sanders and Warren are betting
that they'll be better prepared better
able to sell their populist message to
the people but in an era when Donald
Trump has proven pretty capable of doing
that already with anti-immigrant
rhetoric it is a hard sell indeed and
the late entry of Michael Bloomberg a
New Yorker like Trump a businessman like
Trump and much much richer than Trump is
unsettling the president he doesn't have
the magic to do well little Michael will
fail I'm a New Yorker I know how to take
on an arrogant con man like Donald Trump
he could spend 1 or 2 billion dollars in
the general election basically evening
out that financial Vantage that Trump
will have is the incumbent yet Michael
Bloomberg's ability to
liver a Trump beating strategy like
every other candidates appears flawed in
allegations tonight of sexism against
Michael Bloomberg Bloomberg is now a
target defending his controversial
police policy of stop and frisk with no
perfect candidate the Democrats best
strategy is to keep voters focused on
Donald Trump's feelings rather than
their own if it ends up being a
referendum do you like Trump or not like
Trump Trump can be beat if it is a
choice between what Trump's presenting
and what the Democrats are offering
that's where Trump has a good chance to
get reelected hello I'm John Prado I'm
the economists us editor to keep up to
date with all our coverage of the 2020
presidential election please sign up to
our checks and balance newsletter
there's a link to do that opposite it'll
arrive in your inbox every Friday with a
selection of stories from The Economist
and some other good stuff in there too
don't forget to subscribe and thank you
for watching